John the twos Matuszak was just as
famous in the 80s for his hard-partying
larger-than-life persona as he was for
his football game but even if you didn't
know him for either of those reasons you
definitely knew about his alter ego the
enormous gentle sloth whose
unconventional appearance was the face
of the 1985 classic The Goonies in a lot
of ways sloth wasn't just the on-screen
alter-ego of the former football star he
was the actual manifestation of the
person Matuszak was on the inside a
lovable giant who was also a generous
friend after attending a few different
colleges including the University of
Missouri where he got kicked out for
punching a guy at a party he landed at
the University of Tampa the NFL took
notice of a six foot eight frame so much
so that the Houston Oilers selected him
number one overall in the 1973 Draft
unfortunately though the man behind
sloth didn't get his happy ending vodka
and valium during his second season with
the Oilers Matuszak was traded to the
Kansas City Chiefs who traded him to the
Washington Redskins who cut him just two
weeks later at the end of the 1976
preseason why was his stint in
Washington so short-lived according to
coach George Allen vodka and Valium this
reputation for drinking debauchery would
only get worse I didn't know anything
about John Matuszak other than he was
supposed to be nuts hard-partying ways
after Washington cut him loose Matuszak
was a free agent and the Oakland Raiders
were desperate after three of their
defensive lineman suffered season-ending
injuries so they pretended they didn't
know about the vodka and Valium
it made Mateusz decorator coach John
Madden told ESPN when he arrived I
wasn't about to talk to him about his
past if you know too much about a guy
you tend to prejudge him to hold his
past against him the gamble paid off in
Mateusz axe first season the Raiders won
their first Super Bowl title but
afterward he gradually began to fall
back into his hard-partying ways he
always played well though so he managed
to get away with all the headline-making
hijinks Mateusz axe ex-fiance Stephenie
Cozart recounted to the LA Times the
number of times he committed himself to
rehab and then walked out before
completing the program she revealed I
have a little velvet box at home it's
full of 30 day and 60 day chips the
those out at the a a and CA meetings his
big goal was to get a 90-day chip and he
never got one no lessons learned in his
autobiography cruisin with the twos
Matuszak describes six separate
incidents involving automobiles that
each resulted in convictions according
to the LA Times he had an excuse for all
of them ranging from swerving to avoid a
child to not knowing there was marijuana
in the car in one incident he attacked
the other driver before fleeing the
scene but he never wanted to take
responsibility for his actions
according to ex-fiance Cozart it was
never his fault and it never had
anything to do with the fact that he was
high final straw
football often leads to injuries and
because of one he sustained Matuszak sat
out the 1982 season and then decided to
retire from football altogether the pain
and resulting medications were the final
straw after years of hard partying and
drug abuse in 1989 at the age of 38 he
passed away after accidentally
overdosing on the painkiller darvocet
after the coroner's report was released
his parents admitted that their son used
prescription and illegal drugs to try to
cope with chronic back pain they added
in a statement at the proper time we
will have things to say about substance
abuse in the scoundrels in the medical
profession who recklessly dispense
prescription drugs and the parasites of
society who distribute illicit drugs
from back alleys to fashionable
condominiums lovable giant in the midst
of all this it's worth remembering that
John Matuszak had a big heart he was a
brawler a partier and a guy who didn't
want to take responsibility for his
actions but that wasn't all well I'm
really not meaning personality at all
but when you play the game of pro
football
it's like assuming a character in a part
he was also known for his generosity and
often visited sick children Jeff Cohen
who played chunk and Goonies shared John
was really nice to me and it was fun to
work with him but it's funny when I was
a teenager and I would start to watch
the old NFL films he would just terrify
people on the field which was totally
shocking to me I knew him as sloth the
nice loveable giant according to the New
York Times the coroner's report also
listed bronchial pneumonia and an
enlarged heart as factors that
contributed to his death unfortunately
the Tuesday's big heart just couldn't
handle all the excesses it had been
forced to endure over the far too short
life of the man of law
to
[Music]